amber heard johnny depp's former wife uh
has claimed that the hollywood star
threatened to kill her many times she's
giving evidence at the libel trial which
he's launched against the sun
newspapers accusations of wife beating
well let's get more on that story from
our correspondent rasheed who's outside
the high court in
central london and
more extreme revelations today in court
that's right those extreme revelations
continuing now into a third week of this
trial adam we've been hearing from
johnny depp's former
wife amber heard also an actor who has
been giving
evidence on behalf of the sun's
publisher
news group newspapers over the last
couple of hours
uh in court 13 in the high court just
behind me there they've just broken for
lunch now so they'll be returning
just after two o'clock but as a reminder
we've already had two weeks of
high drama inside the court here and
amber heard has been watching on for
those
past couple of weeks as her ex-husband
the
hollywood star johnny depp has been
giving evidence
as well we've heard some quite gruesome
and dramatic details
of their relationship now this all has
come about because of an article that
the sun wrote back in
2018 in which they allege that johnny
depp was
a wife beater and also in there were 14
incidents of alleged violence towards
amber heard all which johnny depp
completely
denies now in a written witness
statement which was given
to the court today by amber heard
she accused johnny depp of subjecting
her to
verbal and physical abuse she included
in there screaming
swearing issuing threats punching
slapping
kicking head and choking her as well as
extremely controlling and intimidating
behavior as i mentioned this was a
written witness statement which was
handed out to the quarter
a 40-page document and in there amber
heard says that
some incidents were so severe that i was
afraid he was going to kill me
either intentionally or just by losing
control
and going too far he explicitly
threatened to kill me
many times especially later in
our relationship over the last couple of
hours or so she has been
cross-examined by the lawyers for johnny
depp but also
in that witness statement she spoke
about the way he talked about our
relationship being
dead or alive and telling me that death
was the only way out
of the relationship now as johnny depp's
lawyers have been questioning
amber heard they've been talking about
her use of
alcohol and drugs you remember in the
first week of this trial
johnny depp was questioned hugely over
his misuse of drug
and alcohol saying that he'd been taking
it for a very long time and
a number of substances he'd been taking
as well and whether that
had led to any anger that it incurred
between the relationship of
amber heard and johnny depp but she'd
been talking
about her drug and alcohol use saying
that it wasn't toxic
she said that she didn't drink
excessively or take cocaine
whilst they were in a relationship but
johnny depp's lawyers
say that that is a lie so clearly
another drama fuel day here at the high
court as amber heard gives evidence
for the first time in this libel trial
between johnny depp and the publisher
of the sun's newspaper and that drama
will continue throughout this afternoon
anders amber heard gives evidence over
the next couple of days